[Applause]
yo can we uh
can we talk about billy how old is she
she's old enough right
yeah she is find out i mean yeah she's
on the cover of vogue and
bro who knows maybe putting young girls
on the cover of both problems
of age she's of age okay you're dude
catholic [ __ ] over here well you
have magazines
the heavies she has super heavies and
and she's dyed her hair she's not doing
that whole like uh
green yeah what was the the mortal
kombat character
not scorpion not uh sub-zero
shiva their green brother
that's taking way too long for this joke
reptile holy [ __ ] al was he in the new
movie
no you just knew that from back in the
day
yeah that's what i was wearing bro
anyway so she's out here um
and for whatever reason it's a big
[ __ ] deal that she's uh on the cover
of vogue
yeah i don't get it i don't know much
about billy eilish i like the songs i
hear that's all i know yeah
she seems like an artist but that's you
know i was reading what she said it was
kind of cool
what she said what'd she say she like
i mean like i'm probably gonna misquote
her but it was something like uh
because i didn't wear like super sexy
clothes yeah
when i was younger people thought that i
was all like for like body positivity
and stuff like that
and now that i'm older and doing it like
they feel like i've kind of like
sold out yeah and she's like i just i
want to be desired
fire i think she kind of said that good
for you maybe look at the quote just to
make sure
but uh mission accomplished
maybe she wasn't desired because she was
a [ __ ] teenager yeah that's the way
you should do it yeah
bag your ass clothes until you're of age
and then wear what you want bro
i think we had a podcast where i was
literally saying that i get to choose
what my daughter wears until she's 18
years old yeah
like this is fine yeah yeah you over
here want to inject your kids with
[ __ ] training hormones
okay she's going to be wearing some tits
okay i can't wait wearing some balls
but uh but yeah i don't know i think
it's i think it's kind of cool let's see
what she said
so she's got this thing i don't know
83.4 million
she's also homeschooled she's so she
didn't get that typical high school
experience of like
being desired trying to change her looks
a billion times like she just learned
from her older brother and in fairness
i actually thought the like the photos
were like tasteful i guess
yeah like they're not like they're like
sexual but they're not like
she's like monroe yeah yeah they're not
overly professionally done
yeah yeah i mean you know it's just a
big change from what she's put out in
the past like this is the first time
she's put out like sexy
are people upset about this uh i think
people are standing in it they're like
some people kind of feel like she's
switching up on them
yo what happened to her body her choice
okay
why is it that like this annoys me about
the feminist movement a little bit i'll
be honest like
they always say ladies you could do
whatever you want with your body as long
as it's what i want you to do that's
your body yes
yes kind of affect like yo if you want
to dress like that and show the puppies
then you can show the puppies
and if you want to cover them with the
baggy shirt cover with the baggy shirt
yeah
i don't know my hate is like you're a
role model as long as you do what i tell
you
yeah or you do what i agree with i just
want to model what kind of role you play
like i want to
yeah you know what i mean yeah yeah
that's kind of cool to fit
maybe they're like pissed that she's uh
like potentially
selling out for the male gays yeah cause
she goes it's just
fat girls upset she's not fat yeah
that's right that's all
once fat girls lose a fat girl they're
pissed you ever notice that
nah that's true the second yeah that's a
great point yo
fat girls do not like rebel wilson
suddenly ain't that funny anymore all of
a sudden they hating on rebel wilson
right adele got skinny they was hating
on her too
fat girls don't like to lose one bro
yeah adele needs to put it back on she
looked better when she had a little
there's some people look better fat
jonah
adele donald he'll look much better fat
much better fat he's a much better
looking fat but good for her she want to
show it off show that [ __ ] off
[ __ ] i think it is unbelievable
unbelievable
that any girl who has it physically
and doesn't use it like that to me is
unbelievable
because think of how hard she got to
work in order to get
likes on her instagram posts yeah that
part is kind of cool i think she gets
more respect for it
in that regard like she built his career
off of like talent and personality
and then said and then she would she did
it when she
she did it on her terms yeah it's not
like she was falling off and then she
started popping her [ __ ] right yeah
she's at the height of her career and
she's like
okay i also got the heavies that's cool
yeah
i'm with that if everything wasn't
working out she's like let me put out a
sex tape or whatever these cornball
[ __ ] do
yeah then that's whack you already made
it without using your body at
all we had to wait for the wind to hit
you in a [ __ ] blouse before we knew
that you had some big old tits right
like [ __ ] on reddit which we're
nerding out there like yo did she got
some sneak titties
nobody knew and then she [ __ ] made it
and now that she want to show it after
she made it on her own merit on her own
talent you gonna hate on her
no that's the way you do it yep that's
the way you do it she won
she won because low-key she could throw
the sweatshirt back on and still pop
because that's how she was popping thank
you or now she can live that easy life
just showing off the heavies
the question is is she going to go back
because now she knows how easy it is to
get attention
you show a little your top of your titty
and the whole world is having
conversations about you
we never talked about her before in this
podcast that's true you show the top of
your titty you get conversation on
flagrant too
caitlyn step it up keep showing your
flavor
she's doing it tastefully though because
i think there are some women that
you know maybe made it to where they're
at not being all sexual and now they're
trying to be sexual and it looks kind of
corny or forced
and so the way that she's doing it at
least right now it's
tasteful and it's like it's not that bad
but if she starts if she starts the only
fan for example i'm gonna be like nah
yeah cause the only fan is fans is like
yo i need money
yeah like she's doing this cover of what
is it vogue
you don't get paid i think when you do
the cover for these magazines you don't
get paid
no no it's just a clout push yeah so
it's like
they're tagging you this is the old
school tag me in a photo
right so she's doing vogue for free
for clout which is cool i'm okay with
and when you go do it you can't go there
with the green hair the whole thing
about vogue i imagine this is a fashion
magazine
do something unique do something
different like be different be a
different
version of yourself and we're going to
help you be the best version of yourself
that's different
and then put you on a magazine we don't
want the same image of you before right
looking like what is it reptile looking
like reptile right
evolved she evolved why you mad for
evolving yeah yo
god bless billy eilish